law enforcement sources tell CBS News
Whitey Bulger apparently was severely
beaten by mu 1 or more inmates before
his death in prison
the notorious mob boss was found
unresponsive in his cell yesterday he
was serving a life sentence for his role
in 11 murders and other crimes other
reports say he was targeted in prison
for being a government informant Nicky
batiste is outside the Hazelton the
federal prison in West Virginia where
brogre died
Nicky good morning good morning whitey
Bulger's death is being investigated by
the FBI in Pittsburgh and federal
authorities here in West Virginia they
will try to determine if the 89 year-old
was beaten to death just one day after
he was transferred to this high-security
prison for many victims of James whitey
Bulger's reign of terror his violent
death Tuesday seemed all too fitting he
deserved a slow death and that's what I
hope he got I'm gonna buy myself a ball
with champagne and I'm gonna pump that
cook we are celebrating the the death of
Whitey Bulger radio host and Boston
Herald columnist Howie Carr says
Baltar's ordered a hit on him after he
started writing about the Irish mobster
according to one of his associates they
they got some c-4 explosives from some
of their crooked FBI agents and tried to
blow me up with it putting it in a
basketball according to the Boston Globe
Boulder's eyes were nearly gouged out
and two inmates including a convicted
mafia hitman were seen on surveillance
video entering Bulger cell Tuesday
morning I'm glad he did it if I could I
put money in his campaign for Bulger
rose to power by ratting out his rivals
in the 70s through the 90s he seemingly
ran the Winter Hill Gang with impunity
having paid off police and FBI agents
Bulger's brutality and ruthlessness
inspired Jack Nicholson's character in
The Departed and Johnny Depp played him
in the movie Black Mass in 1995 tipped
off to an imminent federal indictment
Bulger and his longtime girlfriend
Catherine Greig went on the run landing
him on the FBI's most wanted list
when they were finally found 16 years
later they were using fake
and posing as retirees in Southern
California Scot Gary Ola the FBI special
agent who arrested Bulger spoke with 60
minutes steve Kroft in 2013 I asked him
to identify himself and Acton go over
well he asked me to F and identify
myself which I did and I asked him that
I said are you are you Whitey Bulger
he said yes you're not supposed to be
happy when someone dies but this guy was
a monster a fiend and one of the most
horrible people I ever hope to me
whitey Bulger's lawyer blamed his death
on the federal government in a statement
issued yesterday he said Bulger was
sentenced to life in prison but as a
result of decisions by the Federal
Bureau of Prisons that sentence has been
changed to the death penalty Nikki thank
you